BEN KONYI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So my name is Ben Konyi.
I'm an engineer on the
Dart VM, and I also
do some work with
the Flutter engine.
And I'm here to talk
to you a little bit
about my 20% project, which is
the Dart Reddit API Wrapper,
and how you can use it to
moderate Reddit comments.
So basically, how the
Dart Reddit API Wrapper
came to be was I was really
looking for an excuse
to be on Reddit at
work So here we are.
So this is my first Dart
package and really my first--
[APPLAUSE]
So this is my first
Dart package and really
my first major project
written in Dart.
So DRAW is an open-source
API wrapper for Reddit,
and it's written
completely in Dart,
unlike some of the other Reddit
wrappers for other languages.
And it's very similar
to PRAW, if anyone here
has used PRAW with Python.
So it's a relatively
simple interface
and makes it really easy
to query Reddit and perform
actions.
And of course, it's
open source on GitHub.
So as I'm sure many of you
know, comments on the internet
are absolutely awful.
It's the main reason I don't go
and look at YouTube comments.
So these are just some comments
that I scraped from Reddit
today.
And these are the tame ones.
So as you can see,
moderating is difficult,
and this is how I feel on a
day-to-day basis moderating
a moderate-sized subreddit.
You're trying to plug
holes constantly,
and you can never get them all.
So what I've done is,
using my Reddit API DRAW,
I've also combined it
with another Google
API called Perspective.
So for those of you who haven't
heard of the Perspective API,
basically, you can take a
comment, send it to this API,
and it will rate it
on various criteria--
so how toxic a comment
is, if it's coherent
or not, how inflammatory
it is, if it's
an attack on the
author, or if it's
an attack on the commenter.
So without further ado, I have
a quick demo of how this works.
So we take a look here.
So first of all, as
you can see, there's
really not much code to this--
maybe a combined total
of 25 lines of code.
But if we give it
a quick run here,
hopefully we'll see some
comments coming in that--
come on.
There we go.
As you can see here,
we just had a comment
that came in that
was labeled as spam.
And here's another one,
attack on commenter,
attack on commenter.
So these are all comments
that exceeded a threshold
for these criteria.
And I've redacted the
actual comments out of fear
that some of them might be a
little bit not safe for work,
and I do value my job.
So this is all built
using DRAW, my API,
and just hitting up the
Perspective API endpoint.
And yeah, this will
continue to go indefinitely
until, of course, stop it.
And basically, what
I have here, what
I'm going to be
using this for, for
my daily moderating activities,
is to make active reports.
So I've commented out the line
that actually sends reports
to the moderators because I
don't want to spam moderators
on the funny subreddit.
But as you can see,
it doesn't take
much to write a
simple Reddit bot.
Yeah.
So thank you.
That's all I have.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can find
me here on GitHub,
and I'm always looking
for contributors.
So if anyone wants to
help, I'd be more than
happy to take your help.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]